people of the Internet's retro wreckin
tour here and I'm back with another
animal crossing new horizons video July
is here which means there are new bugs
and fish to catch at least if you're in
the northern hemisphere that is and a
free content update for everyone
straight from Nintendo so we'll start
out with what's new in terms of bugs and
fish then we'll talk about what's in
this new content update last month was
all about the fish and this month is all
about the bugs specifically cicadas lots
and lots of cicadas that's right cicadas
are here in Animal Crossing new horizons
even if you don't plan on catching the
meal definitely notice them thanks to
their high-pitched singing it's not only
the cicadas though in fact there are a
total of 21 new bugs available in the
northern hemisphere starting July 1st so
on trees you'll be looking for the
cicadas shells
sauce tags Miyama stacks brown cicadas
robust cicadas giant cicadas giant stags
scarab beetles evening cicadas and
walking-sticks
you can see the times they're available
here on your screen right now this is a
little checklist that I made to help you
make sure you get all the bugs and all
the fish each month I'll include a link
down in the description below if you'd
like to save a copy to your own personal
device on palm trees you'll need to keep
eyes out for the blue weevil beetle
golden stag horn Atlas horned elephant
horned Hercules
giraffes tag and the cyclomatic stag as
for what's on the ground you'll be
looking for earth boring dung beetles
and grasshoppers in July you'll also
want to find a green walking leaf which
you'll find disguised as leaves you know
the little leaves that usually indicate
a furniture item for you to pick up so
quite a month for bugs guys let me know
down in the comments how many you've
already caught and which ones you're
still after if you're looking to make
the most money you'll want to keep an
eye out for all of the larger horned
beetles particularly the cyclomatic
horned atlas and horned elephant which
all sell for 8,000 bells at nook's
cranny the giant stack comes in at ten
thousand then you have the golden stag
giraffe stag and horn Hercules which are
your top earners at 12,000 bells each of
course you can sell all of these for
even more whenever flick is in town as
for the fish not nearly as busy as last
month but we do still have a few
rivals to discuss you'll find the
Napoleon fish ocean sunfish which is
absolutely huge by the way it's sing
like 30 percent of the screen but look
at the size of that thing man it's
bigger than a great white shark and
puffer fish in the sea the Blue Marlin
at the pier and the sweet fish in the
river the top money makers here will be
the Blue Marlin and the Napoleon fish
which both go for ten thousand bells at
nooks cranny
now unfortunately these are all for
northern hemisphere islands only nothing
new this month for the southern
hemisphere at least when it comes to new
bugs fish both the northern and southern
hemisphere however will be part of the
free July content drop from Nintendo you
can see in the Nintendo teaser here
below that diving is coming to New
Horizons and with diving they'll also be
new creatures to collect which of course
can be donated to the museum in order to
dive you'll need to purchase a wetsuit
from Luke's cranny or using the name
I'll shop app this drop also brings
another returning character to the
franchise with Pascal the otter you'll
encounter Pascal on your dives and it
appears you'll be able to obtain mermaid
themed DIY recipes from it we'll also
see a new pirate themed version of
Gulliver and expect there to be new
items associated with those visits as
well so that's just a very quick look at
what all is coming to Animal Crossing
New Horizons in the month of July if you
want to see more videos like this be
sure and hit that subscribe button
before you go that's gonna be it for me
today I'll talk to you again soon